We just hit 20 million subscribers on this channel, and I am incredibly grateful
And I'm so proud of each and every one of you for joining me on this amazing journey
But before we get started with the celebrations, I have to tell you:
About a year ago, on a charity livestream, I promised that if we hit 20 million subscribers,
I would release my tasteful
nudes
I have said it before, I'll say it again: I would not mind posting TASTEFUL NUDES of myself, so long as they were WELL SHOT and WELL EDITED.
VERY WELL EDITED *laughing*
But I am a man of my word, and available right now for pre-order, is my tasteful nudes
calendar. Chock full of 12 different
compromising images that I never thought would ever make their way to the internet, let alone be sold in a calendar set and I'm very
positive that my mom is not going to be proud of me after this video comes out, now a few things about this calendar:
It's only available for the next 48 hours,
but if you order within those 48 hours, I will personally hand sign
every single calendar that is ordered, and not only that,
but all the proceeds that I would get from these calendars will be donated directly to The Cancer Research
Institute, and in addition to that, this calendar is special because it's not just pictures of me,
but it's also pictures of your favorite egos like Darkiplier,
the Jims, and a few other surprises that you'll just have to wait and see. I know this is probably the weirdest
celebration that anyone has ever done for a subscriber milestone, let alone one as important as 20 million, which is something I never
ever, ever thought that my channel would ever get to.
Uhhh, but.
But I should mention that this this calendar, while I am, yes, naked in the pictures,
it's no worse than like, the ESPN Body Issue, which if you don't know what that is:
it's where they take a bunch of athletes and they... they pose them, and they're naked, but you don't actually see any...
So *laugh* both "you're welcome" and "sorry to disappoint", but my dick is NOT in these pictures! *laughing*
They're tasteful! It's tasteful nudes! So there's tasteful censorship. It's just... it's like it's like just
conveeeeenient
censorship. It's... *laughing*
Basically, it amounts to
PG-13 nudity, which means that nothing's actually shown, it's just implied. But this was a lot of fun to make.
And I'm actually really proud of it! You guys should check it out, the link is in the description below, remember:
it's only available for the next 48 hours, starting at the time that this video was released, so if you don't get it now,
it'll never be available again, so go click the link in the description below, it benefits a great charity,
it's a really cool thing, and I will sign every calendar that's ordered, so you will get something that's personally signed from me,
I don't care how many are ordered,
I will sign every single one. Now, that may mean that it'll take more time to get to you,
but I think it'll be worth it if it gets money to a great cause. So, with that being said, I
wanted to take a moment to really thank you guys, from the bottom of my heart,
I really do appreciate you guys being with me on this journey
It's been just about six years now that I've been
doing YouTube, and that's not a long time in the grand scheme of things,
but these past six years have been so full of life, and so
full of love, and so full of memories that I'll never forget: both good and bad, but
predominantly good.
And it's good because you guys are here, and you guys support me through all of this, and you guys
do so much for me, and I'm so happy to
be able to provide entertainment for you, to provide,
like, reassurance for you when you need it, and to provide encouragement when you... when you don't feel it, and you know,
it's... it's something that I never ever thought would grow to this level.
I've-I've said it a million times, and I'll say it a million times more, but thank you,
from the bottom of my heart,
thank you so much for being with me,  for encouraging me when I needed it the most,
for being there when I didn't feel like I was up to the task.
You know, this-this channel works both ways: I try to encourage you guys, but you guys
encouraged me so much more than you could ever know, I love seeing what you make,
I love seeing all the creativity that's poured out of the community,
I love seeing everything that you do, I love seeing people in the community rise and find success of their own, because you can,
and that's the beautiful thing! Like what I do here is not all that special,
I may work hard, and I may try really hard to make it the best that I can make it, but anyone can do that,
any of you guys can do that, any of you guys can pursue your dreams,
and they may not be YouTube, they may not be artistic endeavors, but whatever you put your mind to.
If you work hard enough, and you rally people to your cause...
If you reach out to the community and you try to help as much as they try to help you,
anything's possible...
So thank you so much for being with me for twenty million subscribers,
thank you for supporting me through these tasteful nude calendars, *laughing*
and thank you for believing in the charitable efforts that I do and the weird ways that I try to raise money for charity.
Just thank you,
it means the world to me
So thank you all so much for watching! Check out the tasteful nudes calendar in the link in the description below, and remember:
I'll hand sign each one, it's only available for about 48 hours and
*whispering* no dick in it... *laughing*
So, thanks again, and as always, I will see you in the next video. *musical-sounding* Buh-byeeee!